here are the nominees for makeup  achievement in makeup aldo seniority and  vittorio Sedano for Apocalypto Kazuhiro  Tsuji and bill course / click  daveed Marty and Mon say reveille for  Pan's Labyrinth Han goes to David Marty  and once every day for panic this is the  first Academy Award and nomination for  day  and once a rebate they have also done  makeup together on films the dark and  bad education  it's very heavy  um thank you very much to the Academy  thank you thank you very much to be your  Moodle torilla that it's a very special  person and very talented thank you very  much to beat your house and Picasso and  take logon and okay where you get your  mo oh thank you very much Guillermo this  is for you thank you very much for this